In the last video I promised
you that I would show a
concrete example of
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
So let's do that right here.
So let's say we have
some benzene.
And it's a solution with
some molecular bromine.
So I'll draw the molecular
bromine like this.
So it's one bromine
right there.
It has one, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven, valence electrons.
And it's bonded to another
bromine that has one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven electrons.
These two guys in the middle
are bonded to each other.
They can kind of act as an
electron pair or make bromines
feel like they have
eight electrons.
This guy thinks he has
a magenta one.
That guy thinks he
has the blue one.
And let's say we have
some iron bromide
in our mix as well.
And what we're going to see is
that this is going to catalyze
the reaction.
So the iron bromide.
We have some iron and
it's bonded to three
bromines just like that.
So we haven't seen iron
bromide much.
But the way I think about it is,
bromine molecules are much
more electronegative
than the iron.
So even though these look like
fair covalent bonds, if we had
thought about oxidation, these
guys are going to be hogging
the electrons.
This actually would have an
oxidation number of three.
And in reality they are
hogging the electrons.
They are more electronegative.
So the way I think about is
that this iron will have a
slightly positive charge.
Because the electrons are being
hogged away from it.
So it wouldn't mind to
gain an electron.
Or it might want to accept
an electron.
It might want to act
as a Lewis acid.
Remember a Lewis acid will
accept an electron.
So this might want to
act as a Lewis acid.
So who can it nab
electrons from?
Well maybe it can nab an
electron from this bromine
right here.
And I'm not saying that this
always going to occur, but
under the right circumstances
if they bump into each other
with the right energies
it can happen.
So this electron-- let me do it
in a different color that I
haven't used yet, this green
color-- let's say this
electron right here gets
nabbed by that iron.
Then what do we have?
Well then we have a situation,
we have this bromine-- the
blue one-- with one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven
valence electrons.
We have the magenta bromine
with one, two,
three, four, five.
Now it only has the sixth
valence electron right here.
The seventh got nabbed
by the iron.
So the iron has the seventh
valence electron and then you
have the rest of the molecule.
So then you have your iron and
it's attached, of course, to
the three bromines.
Just like that.
And then our bonds, these
guys were bonded.
They still are bonded.
And now these guys are bonded.
These were in a pair.
This electron jumped
over to the iron.
And now we have another bond.
But because this bromine lost an
electron-- it was neutral,
it lost an electron-- it now
has a positive charge.
And the iron, now that it gained
this electron, now has
a negative charge.
So let's think about what's
going to happen now.
Now we're going to bring the
benzene into the mix.
So let me redraw the benzene.
And we have this double bond,
that double bond, and then
just to make things clear, let
me draw this double bond with
the two electrons
on either end.
So we have the orange electron,
you have your green
electron right over there, and
I'll draw the double bond as
being green.
Now let's think about this
molecule right here.
We have a bromine with
a positive charge.
Bromines are really, really,
really, electronegative.
You might see them with a
negative charge, but the
positive charge, it really wants
to grab an electron.
And in the right circumstances,
you can imagine
where it really wants to grab
that electron right there.
So maybe, if there was
just some way it
could pull this electron.
But the only way it could pull
this electron is maybe if
this-- because if it just took
that electron than this
bromine would have a positive
charge, which isn't cool.
So this bromine maybe would
want to pull an electron.
If this guy gets an electron,
then this
guy can get an electron.
So you can imagine this thing
as a whole really, really
wants to grab an electron.
It might be very good
at doing it.
So this is our strong
electrophile.
So what actually will happen
in the bromination of this
benzene ring-- let me draw some
hydrogens here just to
make things clear.
We already have hydrogens
on all of these carbons.
Sometimes it's important to
visualize this when we're
doing electrophilic aromatic
substitutions.
So we already have a hydrogen
on all of these molecules.
So maybe this is so
electrophilic it can actually
break the aromatic ring, nab
this electron right there.
So maybe, this electron right
there goes to the bromine.
Maybe I should even
do it this way.
Just to make it clear.
Kind of replaces that one.
Although, obviously the
electrons are a bit fungible.
So maybe it goes over there.
And then when it goes to this--
let me make it clear
it's going to the
blue bromine.
So the electron right here
goes to the blue bromine.
If the blue bromine gets an
electron then it can let go of
this blue electron.
So this blue electron
can then go to this
bromine right over here.
And then what is our situation
look like?
Well if we have that, then let
me draw our benzene ring
first. We have our benzene ring
first. So let me draw the
benzene ring.
This double bond, that
double bond.
Let me draw all of
the hydrogens.
I want to do them in purple.
So we have one hydrogen, two
hydrogens, three hydrogens,
four hydrogens, five hydrogens,
and six hydrogens.
This orange electron is still
with this carbon right here.
But that electron got nabbed
by this bromine.
So that electron got nabbed by
this bromine right over here.
I've kind of flipped it around
and now it has its other six
valence electrons.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
The electron got taken away
from this carbon.
So now that carbon will have
a positive charge.
But we saw in the last video,
it's actually resonance
stabilized.
That electron could
jump there.
That electron can jump there.
So it's not as stable
as a nice aromatic
benzene ring like this.
But it's not a ridiculous
carbocation.
It's stable enough for it to
exist for some small amount of
time while we kind of hit
our transition state.
And then this molecule
over here, what's it
going to look like?
Well this bromine had
a positive charge.
Now it gained an electron.
Let me draw it.
So you have your bromine.
It gained an electron.
So now it is neutral again.
So let's see, it had the one,
two, three, four, five, six.
Now it gained this
blue electron.
So now it's seven valence
electrons.
Back to being neutral.
It's bonded to the
iron bromide.
Let me draw the bromines.
One, two, three.
And so we've given this blue
bromine to the benzene ring.
But it's not happy here.
It doesn't want to break
it's aromaticity.
It wants an electron back.
So how can it gain
an electron back?
Well this thing-- actually let
me make it very clear.
Let me make it clear.
This thing had a negative
charge.
So you can imagine-- and we had
this electron right here.
So maybe this thing right
over here can now act
as an actual base.
It can nab a proton off
of the benzene ring.
Just like we saw in
the last video.
This is now the base.
This whole complex, to some
degree, acted as a strong
electrophile.
Now that we got rid of one of
bromines, this thing might
want to grab a proton now, since
it is positive and will
act as our base.
And will nab one of
these protons.
If it nabs the proton,
than the leftover
electron is still there.
That electron is still there.
Let me do that in a
different color.
I'll do it in red.
That electron is still there.
And then that electron can
be given to that original
carbocation and we'll have a
nice aromatic ring again.
So how would that look?
So you could imagine a situation
where this electron,
this green electron right
here, gets given to the
hydrogen nucleus.
If it's given to that hydrogen
nucleus, then this red
electron right here can then
be given to the carbocation
And then what are
we left with?
Well, we have our-- let me draw
what we started with-- so
we have our ring.
We have this double bond and
that double bond right there.
Now let me draw all
of our hydrogens.
We have this hydrogen, that
hydrogen, this one over here,
this one over here, and we
have this one over here.
Now this hydrogen just
now got nabbed.
So this hydrogen over here got
nabbed, it got given--
actually the hydrogen nucleus
got given this green electron.
It got given this green
electron, which is paired with
this magenta one right
over here.
So it is now bonded
to the bromine.
We now have hydrogen bromide.
And this had one, two, three,
four, five, six
other valence electrons.
I'll keep the colors
consistent.
And this is now bonded.
Now this electron went
away from the iron.
So the iron will now lose
its negative charge.
The iron bromide.
So now it is back in
its original form.
So we have our iron bonded
to three bromines.
We are bonded to three bromines
just like that.
It has lost its negative
charge.
And this electron right here
has now gone to the
carbocation So that electron
right there has now gone to
the carbocation.
It is right there.
So this bond, you can imagine it
now being this double bond.
So it was magenta, so I'll draw
it in magenta just there.
And we can't forget the whole
point of this whole video was
the bromination.
So we now have this
bromo group there.
So we have this orange electron
is right over here.
And it is bonded to
that bromine.
Just like that.
And we have brominated the
benzene ring using-- and just
let's be clear-- we had
a negative charge
and a positive charge.
Now it's canceled out.
The thing with the negative
charge gave an electron to the
positive charge.
It is now neutral.
That is now neutral.
Now let's be clear on
what happened here.
Just to map it to what
we saw before.
We had a benzene ring.
Right here we have no
strong electrophile,
or strong base yet.
It had to become a strong
electrophile.
When this thing gave an electron
to the iron bromine,
it became this larger
molecule.
Now this whole thing can
act as a pretty strong
electrophile.
This grabbed an electron.
It broke the aromaticity
of the benzene ring.
But just long enough for
this bromine to form.
But once this bromine, it gained
an electron and then
bonded to the benzene.
And then gave up an electron
to this other bromine that
really wanted to get an electron
because it had a
positive charge.
And then once it got it,
now this whole thing
acted as the base.
So we kind of have the same
molecule changing up a little
bit, acting as an electrophile
or acting as a base.
And then once it acts as a
base, this bromine, this
magenta bromine, nabs the
proton, allows this electron
to go back to that carbocation
and then we're left with the
iron bromide again.
So this thing really
didn't change
through the whole reaction.
That's why we can call it a
catalyst. It wasn't one of the
reagents, one of the reactants
in the reaction.
Hopefully you found that
vaguely interesting.